and I was just sitting here and I
realized that if you just saw the word
clause you might think this is a really
weird shirt so I'll explain it real
quick it's a cat it's a cat attacking a
mouse and it's claws and it's jaws
it's proof shirt I can't possibly use
that for my intro but I'm gonna Nabors
is directed by nicholas stoller and star
seth rogen Rose Byrne and Zac Efron this
film is about a frat house that is
headed by Zac Efron they move into the
house directly next to the happily
married couple Seth Rogen and Rose Byrne
they have a young daughter a young baby
girl and to some of this plot very
quickly basically they have a really
hard time living next to each other
because it's a fraternity and that's not
fun for a happily married couple
neighbors is one of those films where it
could go both ways you could go to this
movie and then leave and think that was
one of the worst movies I've ever seen
or just wasn't funny at all or it could
actually be really hilarious
I found neighbors to be really funny in
a lot of different ways namely the
chemistry between the stars
I thought Rose Byrne and Seth Rogen were
fantastic together and I mean really
really good Zac Efron also had extremely
good chemistry with Seth Rogen they had
really great scenes together and he was
also pretty funny in the movie himself
when the best parts of this film was
that it wasn't just two opposites who
lived next to each other and they fight
a lot because one of them is playing
really loud music Seth Rogen and Zac
Efron are both in very similar spots in
their lives just in a very different
path see Seth Rogen is right at that
point where he's just had a baby girl
and he's starting to see his youth fade
away and he's going into adulthood and
this scares him a little bit but he's
also kind of excited about it
Zac Efron's character is about to
graduate from college and he doesn't
understand where he is going in life
either and he is at that cusp of leaving
youthhood and turning into an adult and
so in slightly different ways both of
these characters are actually
experiencing the same thing and this
film actually has various poignant
elements like that too mixed in with the
poop and the vomit and the farts and all
that stuff to actually works around the
film because the film takes a very
realistic look at what couples get to be
once they're at a certain spot where
they're like yeah let's just fart in
front of each other that's fine but I
haven't mentioned my favorite part of
this movie it's actually Rose Byrne she
steals this entire film she is so
hilarious in this movie her chemistry
with Seth Rogen
is great but as a character she has so
many great moments in this movie there's
a hilarious scene that I won't spoil
that she just killed it she killed it
I was always kind of hoping she would
get a really good comedic role because
she had really funny parts and
bridesmaids but she was kind of given
like the least funny role in that film
she was so so good in this movie it's
not like a laugh a minute movie it's
just a very fun and entertaining film I
did laugh from time to time but for the
most part you're just watching
characters that are really fun and
enjoyable to be around and you don't
mind it the worst part of this film for
me though was that there are certain
characters in the film usually in
positions of authority whether it's a
Dean at a college or a police officer
that are so incredibly unrealistic to
the point where I was like what that
would never happen in real life I won't
get into too many details but there's a
scene early on in the film involving a
police officer and a dispute between the
neighbors and I was like this is the
most unrealistic thing I have seen in
theaters all year and I saw a legend of
Hercules there just moments like that in
this film that really took me out of it
where you're like wow these people are
definitely not doing their jobs
correctly for the most part though
Nabors is a really fun enjoyable movie
because of Seth Rogen's chemistry with
Rose Byrne and Zac Efron they all work
really well together and I really like
their performances in the film there are
some parts that took you out of the
movie because of how unrealistic it is
but overall I really enjoyed neighbors
and I'm going to give it a B so guys if
you do see the film this weekend let me
know you thought below and as always
thank you so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stigmatized
Oh